The final paper... not the final,
but the last one I got interested in
was written in the late forties
by a couple of German
physicists at Göttingen and...
they had been contacted by an eye doctor at the
clinic and of course the way
medicine works is that, you know, the local doctors
will solve all the cases they know
how to solve and if they find something they
can't help they refer it up the food chain
to the next doctor
and so things keep moving up and so if you're
the head of the eye clinic at Göttingen
it means you're the most
eminent eye doctor in the German-speaking world
ok? So one day that this guy comes to
work and in his waiting room is a man
who's got "floaters." He can see
little dark specks floating around in his
vision which is a very common thing.
So this is like if you're the most
important dermatologist in the world and
somebody comes to see you about a
freckle. He looks into the
guys eye and he sees tumbling around in
the guy's vitreous humor he sees little tiny
metal rods. They're obviously metal.
They're obviously man-made and they're
just floating around loose inside of his
eyeball which is perfectly undamaged.
There's no no entry wound nothing like that.
So he's completely mystified.
He asks the guy, "What did you do during the
war were you in an explosion?
Anything like that?"
The guy goes, no, I didn't fight...
I was a civilian.
Well, what do you do for a living?
I drive a truck.
Well, do you ever like maybe stick
your head out the window or were you
ever in a crash you know or anything like that?
No, nothing like that, doctor.
So eventually he had to give up
and write it off as a mystery of science.
But then a few months later,
another guy shows up.
Same symptoms exactly the same thing.
No explanation for it. And then another
and another.
So he starts trying to put the pieces
together and figure out what is the
common thread among all of these people
and turns out the one thing they all
have in common is that they're drivers.
Which by then met driving trucks, but
during the war because we had targeted
their... the Germans... fuel production
there have been a lot of trucks lying
around that couldn't be operated
because there's no fuel. So they had gone back
to hauling them behind animals and they had
had to improvise harnesses and yokes and
all that stuff because it was all gone
nobody had used it for decades. And
that was all easily invented from ropes and
straps and whatever they had lying
around. But the hard thing was
getting whips. Because whips have some
pretty specific properties that they have to
have if they're going to crack correctly.
But some genius figured out that
one thing they had all over Germany by
that point was collapsed buildings and
a lot of those buildings had running down
the outside a braided copper
grounding cable and if you just went up
to one of them and cut off the length
of that stuff and you know did the right
motion you could get that thing to crack
like a whip. A thing that a lot of
novice whip crackers do is that they jerk
the whip toward them to make it snap
which is really dangerous because it
comes back at you but it's a really easy
way to get it to crack every time.
So the doctor said...
"Did it ever happen when you were doing that
you like would feel you know
one of these sharp pains in your eye?"
And they said, yeah, that happens sometimes, but
you know you just kind of blink it
away. And few minutes later, you know,
it's like nothing ever happened.
So he goes running across the campus
to the Physics department and he
buttonholes a couple of physicists and he says, "Is
it physically plausible that if you cracked
a copper grounding cable like a whip
that the tensile strength of the copper
out at the end would get exceeded
to the point where it would snap. And if so
would the pieces be going fast
enough that they could fly through the air
for a few feet and penetrate
somebody's eyeball and come to a stop
inside the vitreous humor?"
So the physicist, you know,
I mean this is all that whole story is in a footnote!
It's compressed into a footnote on
page 1 of this paper. And then
the rest of the paper is them working
out all the physics of whip cracking and
proving that you know all of those
things could could happen. So as you can
tell that's been a kind of a personal
obsession of mine for...
I'd say that story qualifies as stranger than fiction.